WILLIAM DENNIS: Hi, everyone.
I'm William Dennis, a Product
Manager on Google Cloud working
on GKE Autopilot.
I'll be joined later
by my colleague
Gary, who's going to take
you through a few demos.
I'm excited to talk to you
today about GKE's new Autopilot
mode of operation to help
streamline your application
delivery and management.
Before getting into the
details of GKE Autopilot,
I'd like to quickly go
over some different options
you have today for
deploying your applications.
You can run them the traditional
way on VMs directly using GCE,
or build them for
serverless with Cloud Run.
And sitting in the middle
is Kubernetes with GKE.
As you move up the
layers of abstraction,
from raw VMs where you manage
everything, through Kubernetes,
which offers container
orchestration and management,
to serverless, where you just
provide your container to run,
your operations get easier as
there's less for you to manage.
But your deployment
choices and flexibility
is a little bit
reduced as you go up
the stack at the same time.
That's essentially
the trade-off.
You're trading the flexibility
to deploy things however
you like with the need to manage
all that custom configuration.
So what makes Kubernetes
such a popular choice?
The main reasons I
hear are that you
have some requirements that
are not necessarily solved
by a higher order product.
While it's great if you
can adapt everything
to your serverless-- and
frankly speaking, if you can,
I would recommend it--
a lot of the time, the
reality is there's just
stuff you don't want to change.
Maybe you bring over a bunch
of existing applications.
Maybe you need to run a fairly
complex deployment with state--
that needs an attached
persistent disk.
And sure, in those cases,
people will tell you, hey,
you need to get rid of
that persistent disk
and go use a managed products.
And well, they might be
right some of the time.
But practically speaking,
it's not always an option.
Maybe the state is
for a custom database
that you're the one
responsible for managing.
Maybe there is no managed
solution available,
or maybe you just don't
want to change things.
Kubernetes is a very practical
deployment environment
which understands
that you have a lot
of different applications,
some legacy, some new ones,
and they have
various requirements
that can be pretty complex.
So it is in turn a fairly
powerful system for handling
these requirements.
What about compared to VMs?
Well, if you run
stuff in VMs you
have to manage all these VMs,
which can be quite a burden.
You need to worry about
where your application is
going on which VM.
You have to remember the
health of those VMs, and so on.
Kubernetes sits right in
the middle of this spectrum.
It's not too low level and
it's not too high level,
and that makes it a very
attractive deployment
platform for a lot of users.
Add to this a few other
properties, like the fact
it's based on
open-source technology
so you can move your
deployments around,
and it becomes very
attractive indeed.
Kubernetes can run
pretty much anywhere.
So you might be running
Kubernetes on-prem,
you might be running
in other clouds.
Using Kubernetes in
all these environments
makes your deployments
standardized and portable.
So what are the
actual components
in Kubernetes that offer
this flexibility that
makes it so attractive?
Kubernetes ships
with many components
out of the box,
including Deployment,
for stateless web
applications, StatefulSet,
for custom databases,
and anything else
that needs a persistent disk.
For batch jobs,
there's the Job object.
If you need to run an
agent on every node,
such as to capture logs,
you have the DaemonSet.
Added to this are some
scheduling constructs,
like zonal affinity,
and pod topology
spread patterns that allow
you to design your workload
around failure domains, as well
as priority and preemption that
give you fine-grained access
to the scheduling priority
to enable rapid scaling of
high-priority workloads.
At a technical level,
all these constructs
are represented in
Kubernetes objects
through the Kubernetes API.
You can describe a whole bunch
of things, even at this level,
at the Kubernetes API level,
what zones you want to run in,
or how you want to spread
your pods for fault tolerance.
Say if you want to co-locate
two different apps together
on a node so that each machine
is running the frontend
and backend application, while
at the same time being spread
out over a zone,
you can do that.
Now Kubernetes does have a
bit of a reputation for having
a steep learning curve.
After all, there's a
lot of different things
here, many of which
I just talked about.
And that reputation may
be somewhat deserved.
But let me make a
couple of claims.
Firstly, if you just need
to deploy a simple web
application, then
as my colleague
Gary is going to demonstrate,
it's not that hard at all.
You only need to learn
to API constructs--
a deployment, which
houses your code,
and a service, which is how
you expose your application
to the internet-- that's it.
So don't feel like you have to
learn everything all at once,
but know that it's there if
and likely when you need it.
And secondly, as a
professional, you're
not necessarily always
looking for the simplest
tools out there.
Simple is good,
don't get me wrong.
But what you really
need are powerful tools.
You want to make sure that the
deployment tools you're using
can actually deliver all the
things that you need to do.
And Kubernetes is really
good at doing that,
so I'd say it's worth learning.
Now one of the things that
makes Kubernetes a little more
challenging, though, is
that you traditionally
need to learn two systems.
You need to learn the
Kubernetes architecture-- that
is, the open-source
API components,
above the line on
the screen here.
And you also need to learn
the platform API, like GKE's.
At the GKE layer, you create
the cluster and provision
it with the compute capacity
your workloads need, or set up
autoscalers to do that for you.
And once created, you have
a shared responsibility
for those compute
resources, and may
need to debug node
issues from time to time.
This is just our
Kubernetes works,
and the overhead you incur
for getting the benefits
and power of Kubernetes.
At least, that's
how it used to be.
This is why we created
Autopilot for GKE.
Autopilot joins what we now call
the standard mode of operation,
giving you two ways to use GKE.
With Autopilot, most
of the platform details
are handled for
you automatically.
It's still the same GKE
that you know and love.
We just now have a new
way for you to operate it.
This is the Cluster Creation
page for GKE Autopilot.
As you can see,
it's pretty simple.
In fact, these are
all the settings
you need to get
yourself a functioning,
production-grade cluster.
You just need to give
your cluster a name,
pick the region, and
configure network.
So hopefully coming up
with a name isn't so hard.
As for the region, you may
have a favorite already.
Otherwise, generally
you would just
pick the one closest
to your users.
For networking, if you
have public networking
you don't need to
do anything more.
For private networks,
you just need
to specify your subnets
and ranges like normal,
and that's it.
That's really it.
Sure, there's a couple of
additional security features
that you can enable or
disable below the fold,
or you can just accept
our secure defaults
and change it later
if you need to.
Importantly, there is no node
or autoscaling setup needed.
Just go ahead and click
the Create button,
get your
production-grade cluster.
Going back to the API view of
the world, what does this mean?
Well, basically we shrank the
whole GKE API service down
to a single core,
the create core.
As for the Kubernetes
API, which is
how you represent
your workloads,
well, that's still there.
And this is really the point.
Our goal with Autopilot is to
support most of those workloads
that GKE standard does today.
In particular, we still support
all those stateful workloads
that need a persistent disk.
Our goal here is not to change
the Kubernetes API, just
the platform it runs on.
So how does this work?
How can we still offer most of
the Kubernetes features of GKE
standard, while reducing
the platform API to just the
create function?
Well, with Autopilot, you
describe your workloads
in Kubernetes terms,
as you always have,
like your container image
and the resources it needs.
Once scheduled on a GKE cluster
running in Autopilot mode,
we'll automatically figure
out the node resources
needed to run those
workloads and provision
enough capacity for you.
For example, if your container
requests two CPU cores
and 6 gigabytes of
memory, we'll provision
a node big enough to handle it.
We apply the best
practices that we've
learned from six
years of running GKE,
giving you a production-grade
cluster without the hassle.
So that's handy.
But what about after
the cluster is created?
This is actually where the real
benefit of Autopilot comes in.
With a traditional
Kubernetes platform,
including GKE's standard
mode of operation,
there is a shared
responsibility over the nodes.
While GKE standard handles
the lifecycle of those nodes,
for example, the creation,
updating, deleting,
and offers several
features to help automate,
like auto-repair-- at
the end of the day,
those nodes are still VMs
that you need to manage.
You have admin access to
them and can potentially
modify them to behave in ways
that GKE might not expect.
So for Autopilot, we
looked at this and asked,
do you come to GKE
for the ability
to be the root user
on those nodes?
Or are you primarily looking
to run your own applications
on this platform?
We believe for most, the goal
is to run your own business
applications.
So that's what we offer here.
In this mode you're responsible
for describing your workloads
and running them.
If your workload crashes
due to a bug in your code,
I hate to say it, it's
still your problem.
But most other components
related to the nodes
are now Google's responsibility,
along with the cluster itself.
This is a big deal.
And so with this, we
introduced a pod-level SLA
for the first time on GKE.
It's three 9s.
This means you now have a
cluster that's easier to set up
and easier to manage.
So as a developer,
you're more productive,
and in production,
you spend less time
on the minutiae of
managing the thing,
and more time running
your application, which
is presumably what you're
ultimately here to do.
The third major difference
with this mode of operation
is how resources are built.
Since you describe everything
at a pod level, we bill
you at a pod level as well.
It's kind of intuitive
and it brings
with it some nice benefits.
One benefit is you don't have
to be a so-called Kubernetes
binpacking expert, because you
no longer care if your node has
32 pods or 0, or whether
your node's CPU has
been fully allocated or not.
Because all of that
is now our problem.
Our system is responsible
for packing pods onto nodes.
And if there's any wasted
spare capacity, that's on us.
You don't pay for it.
So it's a really nice
billing model as well.
And with this comes
another nice attribute.
If you're running
a multi-team setup,
you can now figure out how
much each namespace costs just
by adding up all the pod
requests in that namespace.
And we even have tools
to help you with that.
What's more is that Autopilot
comes with a strong security
posture right out of the box.
We implement the GKE
hardening guidelines,
and since the nodes are
more locked down in order
for us to provide
management and that SLA,
you have the benefit of
the reduced node surface
area as well.
You won't need to worry
about unpatched nodes either,
since we will keep everything
up to date automatically.
And if automatic
updates worry you,
fear not, as we
have several tools
to manage that as well,
including maintenance windows
and pod disruption budgets.
So coming back to the Kubernetes
workload constructs I presented
earlier, and one
of the main reasons
why people use Kubernetes in the
first place, let's have a look.
Do they work on Autopilot?
The answer is, for the most
part, yes, and in the same way.
Deployments, stateful
set, jobs, they
all work exactly the same way.
Yes, even that complex
stateful custom database
will just work on Autopilot with
no additional platform-specific
configuration needed.
You can move it right on over.
Let me repeat this,
because it's so important.
We understand that
a lot of users
run stateful workloads
in their clusters.
So when we created Autopilot, we
didn't take any shortcuts here.
Everything just works
for stateful set
as you would expect from GKE.
Now since pods
running on Autopilot
don't have admin privileges,
it does alter some use cases,
especially for DaemonSets.
But this is mostly in the domain
of administrative functions.
The exact type of functions, we
hope, won't be needed anymore.
And we've engaged
several key partners
to deliver their
solutions on Autopilot
for logging, monitoring,
and security in the same way
they work on GKE
standard, covering
many of the popular
DaemonSets that we see.
There's a couple
of other features,
like GPUs, which GKE
standard offers that's
currently lacking in Autopilot.
For the full list, see our
comprehensive Autopilot
overview documentation.
I'll put a link in
the description below.
So we launched Autopilot
about half a year ago,
and companies like
Ubie are already seeing
the benefit of this approach.
Ubie, if you haven't
heard of them yet,
it's an innovative
medical technology startup
based in Japan.
They found that
with Autopilot they
were able to focus
more on doing the thing
that they created
their company to do,
which is to build better
health care solutions, and less
on managing the cluster
and all the infrastructure.
You can read all
about this case study
on our website, which
I highly recommend.
Again, I'll put a link
in the description below.
And with that, I want to
hand it over to my colleague,
Gary, who's going to run
through a practical demo using
Autopilot.
Over to you, Gary.
GARI SINGH: Thanks, William.
In this demo, we'll try
to deploy a standard web
application with a Redis
backend on Autopilot.
The application has
three services--
a Redis leader with a single
replica, a Redis follower,
which actually has three
replicas, and a Redis
and a frontend web
application, which has three
replicas as well.
Now let's deploy
this application.
All right.
Now let's check the
status of our pods.
Now notice that we have one
in the Ready state and several
in the Pending state.
That's because we actually don't
have enough compute resource
provisioned in the cluster.
But not to worry, Autopilot
will handle this for us.
Behind the scenes,
Autopilot is actually
provisioning additional
compute for us.
Let's take a look.
You can see that here
we've added one new node,
and we have two new nodes in the
provisioning status right now.
If we take another
look at our pods,
we'll see that we actually
have a couple more
in the ContainerCreating stage.
We'll wait for a little
bit, but soon we'll
see all of our application.
So all of our pods will
actually be deployed.
All right.
Let's check our pod
status one more time.
All right.
All of our pods are Running.
We'll also notice we now have
five nodes up and running
as well to meet the demands.
Now let's actually test
out this application.
We need to get the address
of the frontend application.
All right.
We can see that the external
IP address here is that.
We'll copy that, paste
it into our browser.
All right.
We have the Guestbook
application.
We'll type in a
few messages here.
All right we'll close this out.
But if all is working, we should
see these messages back again
coming from the cache.
All right.
Our application is up
and running, all as well.
Now in this demo, we showed
the ability of Autopilot
to automatically and
dynamically provision compute
as needed by our workload.
We didn't get into autoscaling,
but William's going
to tell us a bit about that.
And then I'll be back
with another demo
to show you that as well.
WILLIAM DENNIS: Thanks, Gary.
So as Gary showed, Autopilot
will automatically provision
resources to schedule
your pods under the hood,
based on the resources
those pods request.
But what about scaling
the workloads themselves?
For this, GKE offers to
pod-level scaling options.
The vertical pod autoscaler
can increase and decrease
the resources used by the pod.
It does this by
monitoring the resource
utilization of the pod.
And it can adjust
the pod requests,
either increasing it
to improve performance
when it notices more
CPU might be needed,
or decreasing it, when
it sees that the CPU is
being underutilized.
And when you Autopilot,
that's all you need to do.
Autopilot will
ensure that you have
the right node resources
available to run
those resized pods.
And of course, you only pay for
the precise resource requests
of your pod.
To enable in GKE
Autopilot, create
a Vertical Pod Autoscaling
object that references
your deployment.
You can optionally
exclude certain containers
in the pod from the VPA.
I'll put a link to
the documentation
in the description below.
The other workload
scaling option
is the Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler, or HPA.
The Horizontal
Pod Autoscaler can
change the number of pod
replicas in your deployment
based on demand.
With the Horizontal
Pod Autoscaler,
you set a metric to
observe, and a target,
and the HPA will attempt
to create more pod replicas
to keep that targeting range.
For example, if you want
to have 1 pod for every 100
requests per second that
hit your load balancer,
it could do that.
With GKE Autopilot, you can
just set and forget this HPA
and let it handle the
usage spikes for you,
as Autopilot will provision
and de-provision automatically
the compute resources
needed to handle those pods.
And of course, as always, you
only pay for running pods.
To enable, create a
Horizontal Pod Autoscaling
object that references the
deployment to be scaled,
specifying the minimum and
maximum replicate counts,
the metric to be observed,
and your desired target.
Horizontal Pod Autoscaling
can be configured
to use CPU, memory,
or custom metrics,
like requests per second,
or pub-sub queue depth.
Now I'd like to hand
it back to Gary, who's
going to show you a really
cool demo of using Autopilot
with a Horizontal Pod Autoscaler
to handle a pub-sub queue.
Back over to you, Gary.
GARI SINGH: Thanks, William.
In this demo, we're going
to show how to auto scale
a pub-sub workload
based on metrics
provided by Google
Cloud Monitoring.
As you can see, we've already
created a topic named echo,
and a corresponding
subscription named echo-read.
The goal for this demo is to
scale the number of subscribers
for this topic
based on the number
of unacknowledged messages
remaining in the subscription.
As you can see on the
screen, pub-sub conveniently
provides this metric
for us, and later we'll
actually show how to
configure the Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler to use it.
Now this is all made possible
by using the custom metrics
adapter, which will provide
cloud-monitoring metrics
for our cluster.
Now while William was
talking I actually
took the liberty of
deploying this adapter,
so let's take a quick look
just to make sure everything's
running.
All right.
So now we see we have our custom
metrics adapter up and running.
Now we can actually
check to make sure
that the metric that we want
is available by querying
the Kubernetes
external metrics API.
And here in this box,
you'll see that we
have our subscription number
undelivered messages metric.
And we actually see that we have
it for our actual subscription.
So we'll be set up to use
this in the HPA later on.
But before we can
deploy our application,
we'll need to
configure an identity
the app can use to authenticate
with Cloud pub-sub.
Autopilot workloads
use workload identity,
which is the recommended
way to access Google Cloud
Services from applications.
It provides improved
security and manageability
over using things like secrets
or mounting token files, which
are insecure.
First, let's create a dedicated
namespace for our application.
Great.
We'll use the namespace pubsub.
Next, we'll need
to create a service
account that we'll actually
use in our deployment metadata.
We'll call it
pubsub-service-account.
We also need to create a
Google Cloud service account.
And we'll need to
give it permission
to actually access pubsub.
Here you see we're giving
it the pubsub.editor role.
Next, we'll actually bind the
Kubernetes service account
with the Google service account.
And finally, we'll annotate
the Kubernetes service account
so that it knows
about this binding.
Now let's take a look at our
actual application itself.
The actual application
itself is a simple app
which uses a Python SDK to
actually just pull messages
from the subscription.
Now our deployment for this
application is pretty simple.
We have a standard container.
We're going to name it pubsub.
And as you can see
here, we've actually
chosen the serviceAccount
under which
this particular deployment
will actually run.
Now along with that, we
also have a Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler resource.
And as you can see here, we
showed this metric earlier.
We're using the external metric.
We're using the
undelivered messages.
We want this to be for our
echo-read subscription.
And our goal here will be
that we never want to--
no matter how many
subscribers we have,
we want the average value of
the backlog to actually be 5.
All right.
So let's actually
deploy our application.
First, we'll just set
the default namespace
for our context.
Then we'll actually
deploy our pod.
We'll check to make
sure our pod is running.
All right.
We've successfully
deployed that.
Next, we'll actually
deploy the HPA resource.
Let's take a quick look.
Here, we can
actually see that we
have it set up as a
target of 5-- that's
what we configured in there.
The MINPODS is 1 and
the MAXPODS are 5.
And right now we don't
actually have any messages,
so the backlog is 0, and our
Deployment is actually fine.
Now, let's actually
generate some load.
We'll do that by publishing
about 100 messages
to the topic itself.
All right.
Now that our messages are there,
let's take a look at the HPA
itself.
As you can see here, it's
actually updated now.
We actually see that the value
that it's seeing here is 22,
and that it's looking
for a value of 5.
So if we actually
describe the HPA,
we'll see that it actually wants
to trigger up and autoscale
our stuff up to the
max size of actual 5.
Let's take a quick
look at our pods.
You'll see that we've now
actually scaled up to 4 pods,
and we have a fifth pod pending.
So as you can see here, we were
able to build an application,
have it subscribe,
set the metric based
on the unacknowledged backlog
from Google Cloud metrics,
and autoscale our application.
And once again, the
great thing here
was we didn't have
to worry about any
of the underlying compute
resources required for this
to actually work.
All right.
You'll see that our container
is actually creating.
And yeah, that's about
it for this demo.
So thanks, William.
Back over to you.
WILLIAM DENNIS: Thank you, Gary.
That was a really
powerful demonstration
of what Autopilot can do.
All you need to do is add
your Kubernetes workload
and we'll take care
of everything else.
Well, that's GKE Autopilot.
To learn more, you can visit
the link on the screen,
or those in the
description below.
Thank you.